[Musique]
et dans le cadre de cette journée
spéciale consacrée à l'Iran nous
accueillons resa négatif bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes Franco
iranien photos journaliste exilé en
France depuis 40 ans et vous êtes membre
de ce collectif baptisé par ailleurs
persan qui signifie pour il sait de mise
en branle début octobre quand la révolte
a commencé et son objectif c'est de
relayer la voix des Iraniens des
Iraniens dans leur combat quel est le
bilan de ce collectif depuis sa création
nous sommes mi-décembre
bonjour et merci pour cette occasion le
bilan ce qui était pour nous le plus
important c'était de réunir une
ombre importante des grandes artistes
des grands noms français iraniens et
international pour montrer d'une part
leur solidarité avec le peuple iranien
ce qui est son dans les rues de téran
dans les rues de toutes les villes de
l'iranne depuis presque trois mois
maintenant mais de l'autre côté aussi de
montrer que l'art la culture ce sont des
éléments importants et qui peuvent
rapprocher des peuples rapprochés des
gens et à travers ça à travers cette
grande soirée maintenant
nous publions dans les journaux dans une
très grande tribune signée par presque
une centaine de grandes nombres
de culture et intellectuelle français et
nous espérons de continuer ça et faire
comme une coalition de tous les artistes
intellectuels français et européens et
iranienne qui sont présentes pour
montrer aussi
l'impact l'importance de la culture dans
cette révolution des femmes qui est il
faut pas oublier que c'est la première
révolution des femmes dans l'histoire
qu'on connaît les indicatifs vous parlez
bien sûr de ce concert de solidarité
qu'il y a eu cette semaine au Trianon à
Paris votre collectif s'appuie sur la
culture pour se faire entendre alors en
Iran il y a eu des condamnations à mort
deux exécutions neuf autres personnes
sont aujourd'hui menacées d'être
exécutés est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles
absolument depuis le début et depuis des
années même si ça fait 40 ans que je vis
en exil mais j'ai gardé le contact et
c'est surtout grâce à l'internet grâce à
tous les possibilités que offre net
constamment en contact beaucoup de nous
des Iraniens ils sont en contact les
nouvelles c'est beaucoup plus dur et je
dirais terrible de ce que même on les
entend d'ici
en dehors de ces enfants je dirais ces
jeunes condamnés à mort il y a eu des
centaines aussi qui était tué sous les
tortures il y a plusieurs
des enfants ce qui est incroyable et on
sait pas comment une fois que ils sont
arrêtés et soumis à un tour terrible et
relâché et beaucoup de ses enfants ou
ces jeunes
française 17 ans il se suicide et les
médecins n'y savent pas la cause de
cette suicide et il croit que dans la
prison on leur injecte des médicaments
on connaît pas du tout les raisons de
l'autre côté
ils ont dans chaque quartier européen
des jeunes filles ensuite la nuit
l'attaque à 5-6-10 policiers à la maison
il kidnappent les jeunes filles ils les
emmène et vous savez ce qui se passe
dans ce cas-là certains de ces filles
ont trouvé complètement le corps mutilé
violet et mort d'autres on n'a pas de
nouvelles donc c'est vraiment une agonie
de dernière minute de ces mots-là de
cesagnat et leur je dirais leur soutien
qui sont très très peu mais armés
malheureusement il y a eu des milliers
d'arrestations les indicatifs entre ces
morts plus de 450 selon des ONG donc des
centaines de morts depuis le début
jusqu'où selon vous le pouvoir iranien
peut-il aller dans la mesure où il
semble jouer aujourd'hui ça survit
vous savez le régime iranien
il tenait beaucoup à la coalition qui a
créé autour de lui les pays qui
soutiennent le soutenaient je dirais le
régime iranien c'est Corée du Nord la
Syrie la Russie la Chine et l'Arménie ça
c'est les cinq pays qui soutiennent le
régime islamique d'Iran et
grâce à eux il arrivait à dépasser les
sanctions qui étaient menées par
l'Occident par les États-Unis par les
Européens la Chine ils viennent de
relâcher
le régime iranien il y a quatre jours
en faisant une coalition avec l'Arabie
Saoudite et tous les pays de golf ce qui
était un coup très très dur contre le
régime il reste maintenant la Arménie
Corée du Nord et la Russie à la Syrie
ces quatre pays qui sout bien le régime
et la Russie
on ne craignent il arrive toujours pas
devenir ce qu'il voulait faire donc le
régime il a aussi perdu toutes les liens
qui avaient à l'extérieur mais
finalement c'est la rue qui décide et
les gens cette fois-ci après une dixième
grande manifestation dans 40 ans
on voit que cette fois-ci c'est la fin
de régime les allégatives puisqu'on
parle de de l'étranger et un mot
peut-être de la France vous êtes
franco-iranien vous avez trouvé refuge
en France il y a un peu plus de 40 ans
la première ministre française Elisabeth
borne a dit cette semaine que la France
fait tout pour que le régime iranien
sorte de sa logique de répression elle
dit que la France agit de manière ferme
et résolue qu'est-ce que vous avez
compris de cette déclaration que fait la
France à votre avis
nous connaissons pas
les termes par lesquels la première
ministre ou le président français
il réagissent de vendre ça certes il y a
des communiqués on entend les
communiquer mais vous avez de l'autre
côté des pays où qui agissent fortement
l'Italie vient de interdire entrer de
ministères Affaires étrangères iraniens
sur ce sol l'Allemagne fait la même
chose donc ce qu'on demande nous les
franco-uraniens
au gouvernement de sortir de communiquer
et montrer quelques actions la France
comme il était toujours porte drapeau
d'une culture de culture de l'Occident
la France est considérée partout dans le
monde comporte drapeau de liberté de
l'expression il ne peut pas laisser le
peuple iranien
par terre à terre et se faire tuer et
seulement de par quelques communiqués le
condamné nous demandons beaucoup plus de
fermeté de la part de gouvernement
français et ça pourrait prendre quelle
forme cette fermeté resa de Gatti
première nous demandons tous dans tous
les pays aujourd'hui même vous avez des
Iraniens à moi 11
à Oslo il demande que tous ces pays
ils renvoient les ambassades qu'ils
ferment les ambassades parce que pour
ceux qui disent oui mais il faut avoir
les ambassades parce que au moins on a
un lien il se trompe on a déjà vu que
les mots là
il s'en fout de tous des cuillères des
ambassadeurs où il y a pas
d'ambassadeurs à clairante ils font ce
qu'ils veulent ils tuent les gens donc
étape par étape de continuer à
faire rentrer et couper toutes les liens
avec ce régime être plus ferme sur les
sanctions
il y a beaucoup de des gens de régime
voyez des qui ont la corruption par des
milliards qui existent où
ils emmènent leur argent sur Canada
Canada c'est aussi un des pays qui a
donné refuge à plusieurs
dignitaires autorité de dirait pas
dignitaire ils ne sont pas dignes ces
gens-là les autorités régimes iraniennes
qui ont arrivés avec des milliards et
Canada
négatif parviennent
j'ai bien compris que vous demandez à la
France par exemple d'Europe c'est un
lien diplomatique avec
l'Iran l'ancien président iranien
Khatami a dû soutenir les manifestations
est-ce que vous lui faites confiance
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas qu'il
s'agisse de sa part une tentative de
récupération politique du mouvement
oui évidemment que
tout ça première c'est que il faut
jamais faire confiance à un mot là
jamais jamais ça c'est ce que le peuple
iranienne
il a il a dans le sang on a fait plus
confiance à aucun moment ce qu'il dira
Tami c'est pour sauver le régime il est
le régime il voit qu'il est en train de
branler le régime il voit que c'est il
vit cette dernière jour donc par tous
les moyens le même fratami était
interdit par les ayatollahs de radio de
télévision même son image était interdit
jusqu'à il y a trois mois et d'un seul
coup il sort tous les gens en disant
peut-être que lui pourra nous aider
peut-être qu'il pourra mais c'est trop
tard maintenant
aujourd'hui sur tous les poteaux de
nécessité j'ai vu il y a les gens ils
ont mis le nombre de mots là en disant
voilà ça c'est des poteaux qu'on a
réservé pour prendre tellement là pour
chaque jeune qui vont prendre on va
pendre d'Imola dernière question resa
négative vous vous présentez comme un
photojournaliste de paix est-ce que la
paix est possible dans ce contexte qu'on
se considère la fracture entre cette
partie de la population iranienne et le
pouvoir
la génération aujourd'hui iranienne qui
est dans la rue c'est une génération de
paix c'est une génération de la paix et
que il ne veut que vivre normalement
il y a eu un film incroyable que le
régime a voulu montrer en croyant qui
fait bien ce jeune homme qui venait
d'être pendu avec tes yeux bandés on lui
demande quel est ton testament avant de
d'être rendu vous savez ce qu'il dit il
dit ne faites pas prière sur mon corps
ne lisez pas le Coran et soyez joyeux et
faites de la fête
sur mon corps ça c'est ce qui se passe
en Iran ça c'est la génération
allez-y ça sera le dernier mot
oui ça c'est le génération qui est en
train de vraiment emmener une nouvelle
forme de la révolution dans l'histoire
de l'humanité merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup Riza négatif pour votre pour
votre témoignage sur France 24
journaliste photo journaliste
franco-iranien c'était l'invité de Paris
direct dans le cadre de cette journée
spéciale Iran sur nos chaînes merci
beaucoup l'information internationales
continuent sur France 24 et sur France
24 comme prochains journal dans une
poignée de minutes
[Musique]